education is what remains
after one has forgotten what one has
learned in school
if you can't explain it to a
six-year-old
you don't understand it yourself
student is not a container you have to
fill
but a torch you have to light up
life is like riding a bicycle
to keep your balance
you must keep moving
two things are infinite the universe and
human stupidity
and i'm not sure about the universe
anyone who has never made a mistake
has never tried anything new
a clever person solves a problem
a wise person avoids it
try not to become a man of success
rather
become a man of value
i know not with what weapons world war 3
will be fought
but
world war 4
will be fought with sticks and stones
[Music]
any fool can know
the point is to understand
it is not that i'm so smart
but i stay with the questions much
longer
blind belief in authority
is the greatest enemy of truth
we all know that light travels faster
than sound
that's why certain people appear bright
until you hear them speak
genius is one percent talent
and 99
hard work
i'd rather be an optimist and a fool
than a pessimist and right
you never fail until you stop trying
if you want to live a happy life
tie it to a goal
not to people or things
[Music]
only a life lived for others
is a life worthwhile
wisdom is not a product of schooling
but of the lifelong attempt to acquire
it
[Music]
i live in that solitude which is painful
in youth
but delicious in the years of maturity
only those who attempt the absurd
can achieve the impossible
what a sad era
when it is easier to smash an atom
than a prejudice
life is a preparation for the future
and the best preparation for the future
is to live as if there were none
the only source of knowledge is
experience
possessions
outward success
publicity
luxury
to me these have always been
contemptible
i believe that a simple and unassuming
manner of life is best for everyone
best for both the body
and the mind
[Music]
the only sure way to avoid making
mistakes
is to have no new ideas
three great forces rule the world
stupidity
fear
and greed
past is dead
future is uncertain
present is all you have
so eat
drink
and live merry
intelligence is not the ability to store
information
but to know where to find it
do not grow old no matter how long you
live
never cease to stand like curious
children before the great mystery into
which we were born
weak people revenge
strong people forgive
intelligent people ignore
[Music]
it's strange to be known so universally
and yet be so lonely
never memorize something
that you can look up
example isn't another way to teach
it is the only way to teach
once we accept our limits
we go beyond them
one day you will regret that you did not
hear these quotes earlier do not lose
the opportunity watch our next video